Roald Dahl and James Bond... and 7 other Amazing
Facts
1.
Famed sex therapist Dr. Ruth Westheimer was
once a sniper of the Israeli Defense Force.
She was also a survivor of the holocaust,
but unfortunately the rest of her family was
killed.
Dr. Ruth had this to say about her sniping
days: “When I was in my routine training
for the Israeli army as a teenager, they discovered
completely by chance that I was a lethal sniper.
I could hit the target smack in the center
further away than anyone could believe.
Not just that, even though I was tiny and
not even much of an athlete, I was incredibly
accurate throwing hand grenades too.
Even today I can load a Sten automatic rifle
in a single minute, blindfolded.”
(QF 696)
2.
While many people fear flying, nobody seems
to fear sleeping in a bed.
Yet in 2013, according to The Aviation Safety
Network, only 265 people around the world
who traveled via a commercial airplane holding
14 or more passengers lost their lives because
of a plane crash (out of about 31 million
flights), while in the United States alone,
according to the Center for Disease Control,
falling out of bed accounts for about 450
deaths, 400,000 hospital admissions, and 1.8
million emergency room visits each year.
(QF 695)
3.
While most people connect historical African
slave trade almost exclusively with the United
States, the truth is that the U.S. was third
in this sad statistic, importing about 400,000
slaves.
Jamaica rang in at over a million and nearly
5 million went to Brazil.
(QF 690)
4.
While you know Roald Dahl for his best-selling
children’s books such as Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory, Matilda, and James & the
Giant Peach, you may not know that he also
wrote one of the most famous Bond films, You
Only Live Twice (1967).
(QF 688)
5.
The largest employer in the world is the United
States Department of Defense with a little
over 3.2 million employees.
Next up is the People’s Republic of China
with 2.3 million employees, then Walmart with
2.1 million…
(QF 680)
6.
In 1990, Chuck Norris became the first Westerner
in history to be awarded an 8th degree Black
Belt (Grand Master) in Taekwondo.
In his life, he’s also achieved the rankings
of 10th degree black belt in Chun Kuk Do;
9th degree black belt in Tang Soo Do; and
black belts in Brazilian Jiu-Jitsu and Judo.
Apparently some rumors about Chuck’s supposed
superpowers might be true after all.
(QF 676)
7.
The record for the woman who’s had sex with
the most men in 24 hours is currently held
by adult film actress Lisa Sparks, who had
sex with 919 men in just under 12 hours on
October 16, 2004 at the Eroticon in Poland.
Given this, you might be surprised to learn
she’s been happily married to the same man
for over 18 years now, getting married when
she was 18 and he 20.
(QF 659)
8.
The two women behind “Ask Ann Landers”
and “Dear Abbey” were feuding twin sisters-
Esther Lederer and Pauline Phillips respectively.
The source of their dispute was reportedly
the fact that after Esther took over the Ann
Landers column in 1955 (with the original
writer being Ruth Crowley from 1943-1955),
Pauline decided to start up her own competing
column with the same theme, “Dear Abby”.
However, they supposedly settled their differences
shortly before Esther died in 2002.
(QF 657)